seven moderate gun owner Gary Tim the
gun owner I own three shotguns I own
three pistols my hobbies are listening
to music model railroading I will choose
one and change their mind about guns
welcome to the moderate like our first
guests coming up that beautiful Enderson
castle it's a balmy six degrees I'm
looking for someone to fall in love with
my ID is Gary nice to meet you
thanks for uh pulling the trigger and
coming on out very good David nice to
meet you oh just Everett just everybody
just dips to calls gonna get in
there yeah
[Music]
welcome to historic Henderson Castle and
historic Kalamazoo excited taught you
guys one-on-one get to know you
we're gonna talk about life love guns
mostly guns mostly be talking about guns
hi tell me who is David the gun owner
David the gun owner is a kid that grew
up in a household that had literally a
firearm in every corner did you grow up
in mogadishu Wellsboro Pennsylvania
Wellsboro Pennsylvania very rural built
my first firearm with my grandfather
I built a savings account with my
grandpa so similar let's try to find
some common ground on things that don't
involve killing something I like comedy
great you see my stuff I have not even
though you're all over YouTube I didn't
even sit and watch any of that I did
look up your bio to know that you were
from Kalamazoo great but nom you didn't
you didn't see any of the videos no I
thought it very well I'd love to talk to
him more about this by Rick
hi I'm Rick I'm from Detroit Michigan I
run a blog called legally armed in
Detroit my relationship with firearms
started approximately 11 12 years ago I
was surprised by - 19 20 year olds who
were armed with the gun I went and I
purchased a firearm then I made a
decision to become a firearms instructor
definite vibe going on with Rick maybe
we'll get a chance to talk a little bit
later
there are a lot of fully loaded mind
here that I could see myself going to
the range with literally I've taught
thousands of women how to shoot the self
confidence that they get out of learning
something new doesn't necessarily have
to be a firearm do and then you get self
confidence after absolutely they do I
hit it off better with some than others
I don't like the word assault weapon
every weapons an assault weapon mm-hmm
if I wanted to take your life bad enough
that is a weapon
there is one mind here I know I'm going
to relate to because I'm literally
related to him does a piece what up
beats a great guy a note of my entire
life
I was the houseboat the duck boat is
very good you don't have a House bill
Nelson he has not been around the family
much lately his whole career has taken
him away from the area and so he's kind
of out of touch I know Pete the cousin
don't repeat the gun owner I have three
guns there are all shotguns and I
strictly use them for hunting Pete
listens which is great because I like to
talk to and add people thank you to
yourself open-minded when it comes to
guns I would be willing to discuss
that's almost a yes
group date time I really need them to
show me why they deserve to have their
minds changed NRA is is a it's a great
program they're the ones that are gonna
go and fight for our rights if you don't
know how a gun works really you're
scared of it we're whatever I brought
three copies of the Constitution just in
case senator moment I don't know what we
were gonna encounter today Jordan the
simple truth is we have to take care of
the drug trade more people died from
heroin overdoses than they do from gun
shots in this country it's like machine
gun fire out there this is perfectly
quiet your wife won't even know you were
shooting upstairs I live in New York
there's there's no upstairs do you want
to take a little walk outside we can't I
had a chance to talk with George there
was some give a tank back and forth some
good exchanges I'm armed unless I have a
reason not to be fundamental safety is
the responsibility of each individual in
that law enforcement if he was willing
to share where he's coming from and see
where that conversation goes I'd be open
to it this is really hard
unfortunately some of you have to go
home tonight I think Ian you have a hard
out at 7:00 for a parent-teacher
conference yes
in a way it's goodbye now is the time I
have to choose one of you
whose mind I will change
and I choose
Pete Pete will you be my moderate
absolutely why not use Pete he seems
moderate and open to discussion but I
try to change that Doh me yours
good luck with that great well he's my
cousin I'm less likely to get shot by a
family members
really it's the pencil guy still here
everybody else thank you
[Music]
so that foul repeat come just yeah